so we're back in a financial Matt's plot
of the syllabus and we have so far done
three subtopics in financial mess and I
wonder if you remember what they are FM
one by the start of this year a very
first thing you going to do if you want
to talk about money is you need to get
the money for that we call that early
and once you've got it you want to be on
say like okay I think I'm managing is
where we begin and then we said okay
once you've got your money once it's in
your possession you want to be able to
put it to good use right so we said well
maybe you want to buy some shares or
maybe you want to invest that in a
company of some time so that's what FM 2
is about now FM three blink and you'll
miss it was a very very small thing but
very important and those taxation which
we did is very reason these were all the
brilliant parts of financial maths now
we're in an HSE part of financial mass
FM four is called credit and borrowing
now the reason why I'm drawing your
attention to FM one two and three is not
just because it's always good to have
that context of where you've come from
where you're going but also this idea of
credit and borrowing is very closely
linked to one of the ideas that you've
already looked at credit borrowing
credit boating is closest in spirit an
idea to investing in fact as I'm going
to try and demonstrate to you maybe
you'll enjoy this table for me credit
borrow is just investing looked at from
the opposite side of me okay so let's
think about these two transactions
together right the two transactions that
I want us to compare investing and bar
okay so we'll just keep it as simple as
we can
misty yeah
in both investing and borrowing there is
a temporary change of hands in terms of
like funds or sometimes right so there's
a transfer of funds if you are investing
in say some shares right you what some
shares off in the universe like exchange
where is the money being where the funds
being transferred from and to who has
the money in who's giving it to someone
else when you're investing when you're
dusty it's now I'm thinking about just
the funds right just the hunt
so really it's from the investor which
for our intensive purposes is like you
and that money changes hands and you put
it in the bank account of the company
right so you give this money over and in
return they give you something called a
share rights okay you've got you earn a
little bit of this company okay so you
become a shareholder by paying this
little amount of money or maybe a big
amount money depends on the company now
again there's a transfer of funds when
you borrow money I'll give you the easy
bit remember I said this is the same
idea that looked at it from the opposite
direction so you are now on the
receiving end of money when you're
borrowing money okay generally speaking
where would you borrow money from I
think generally speaking of course there
are other people you could get a we
could borrow from you could borrow from
a loan shark if you're in trouble
or from your parents all of this same
concept just slightly different okay now
why why what's the purpose what is the
intentional rationale behind why we
would move funds back and forth between
people well let's think about this
imagine you're the company you're the
company and you're like I want to you
know float our company actually shell
out such shares to people why do you do
this
what's the point mmm I want now look at
use the word revenue we tend to use the
word revenue feel like I actually this
is money that we've bought but yeah it's
temporary it's like no no this is not
really your money as a company it still
belongs to them it's just fit then
loaning it to you if I'm opposed to
starting up a company and I'm like I've
got all these dreams for places I can
develop products that I can create okay
but I didn't have the funds like I don't
have immediate access to it so that's
why I get other people to invest in me
right so maybe I want to like highest
off which costs money okay but I don't
have that money right now but if you
Vestas can give me some then I can use
that to pay their wages right and from
there I can grow the company I can hire
stuff I can develop products which again
I hope these are just examples of what I
can do investors money yeah basically
right I mean the whole premise of
shocked techies stand up and and lobby
and say look these people with huge
amounts of money will you let me some of
it because if ITIF you give to me I can
use it right that money's not doing any
good for you just sitting in a big pile
but I can do something like this right
now that's why we might invest in a
company to enable them to do this why
might we borrow money from the bank
what's the purpose okay maybe you want
to buy maybe you would buy a car okay if
you buy a house we tend to give that a
special names that's of an M right but
it's the same principle just with a
slightly different name say again I
can't get all kinds of little costs that
come a little way between th back focus
study and gravy we know there's lots of
costs
I'm gonna go out on a limb and say that
in 18 months
15 months a whole one of you are going
to borrow a big sum of money because
you're going to never use stage of your
life whether it's University or take
whatever you are going to have to pay
tuition fees of some kind which can be
quite expensive my sister's a dentist
and I'm a dentistry degree really pricey
much so even then right we give a
special name if you go to university to
like not a house which is a mortgage we
call the tuition fees the water that you
take out the boring we call that hex
right higher education contribution
scheme because actually what's built
into that is how you pay money yeah I
always thought that that means a baby
okay now
yeah in Australia it was free for a
period of time our parents some of our
parents generation okay now there's one
last pieces puzzle right which allow us
to compare these two things there's a
transfer of funds between groups of
people so that the group of people who's
getting the money can do something with
that money right so it's like cool you
you get this huge benefit well the
company may get this huge benefit okay
well if there's anything we learn from
economics there's no such thing as a
free lunch
so in order to pay for this this whole
transfer whether it's investing or
barring kind of comes with this IOU like
hey it's doing me a favor right now when
you're investing you buy the shares from
the company they do all this cool stuff
and hopefully their company grows and
they pay money the company pays money
back to you right what do we call that
in more investing concepts from their
profits starts with a D they give you
dividends right yes good I hope this is
reading some bells okay this is just the
special name given to it but it's simply
just like it doesn't matter what name we
give to it it's just a representation of
the fact that hey you did the company a
favor
in good faith that they would do good
things with your money faster stuff and
now they're rewarding you good faith I
have a look down here to here right it's
the bank did you a favor then what's
gonna happen I'm over here you've got to
pay back the bank and we call that not
dividends but interest now it's
important you get different label but it
is the same reality it's just looked at
from a different person's point of view
so therefore all the ideas that you
learned back in fm2 all this kind of
stuff is going to apply yet mmm
okay we should all get some slightly
different applications